if you've ever visited a natural history
museum
you've probably seen timelines like this
or
maybe branching ones like this showing
you the evolutionary chronology of
familiar mammal species and in most of
these timelines if you go
all the way back to the beginning you'll
find a pint-sized version of a mammal
you know today
this isn't a coincidence modern mammals
originated from tiny species
able to outlast the extinction event
which wiped out the dinosaurs and then
grew
in size and diversity over millions of
years to fill out the ecological niches
the dinosaurs left behind in their wake
as a result of this shared origin
looking at the first draft of mammals so
to speak
kind of feels like you're looking at
someone's baby photos
and most of these miniature ancestors of
the species we know today emerged during
the same period
the eocene period a geological epoch
which gets its name from greek terms
meaning new dawn
an appropriate moniker considering the
aocine represented the dawn of modern
mammals
so let's take a look at the tiny mammals
who populated this period
and better understand their connection
to the mammals we know today
beginning with the moaetherium this
extinct genus of rotund stubby aocine
mammals is a distant relation to none
other than mammoths and
elephants the size and body shape of
these tiny animals make the
moe aetherium look more like a modern
pig than an elephant
standing at only 70 centimeters or 2.3
feet high at the shoulder
the shape of their skulls suggests they
didn't have fully formed trunks like a
modern elephant either but more of a
stumpy upper lip for grasping aquatic
vegetation although maybe an
offshoot instead of a direct ancestor to
modern elephants it's still amusing to
think that
other species in this diminutive
taxonomic order would one day become the
largest land animals on the planet
here's another genus from the early aoe
scene which looks quite different from
its gigantic descendants
this is the ambolodectus the four-limbed
ancestor of the modern whale
their name means walking whales because
scientists once believed they were
amphibious and could walk on land as
well as swim although most modern
research suggests they were in fact
fully aquatic the concept of a sharp
tooth for a whale with legs is still
pretty incredible
most modern whale species actually have
trace remnants of vestigial leg bones in
their tails however
from this early land to ocean transition
period pretty interesting
what's also interesting is ambolodectus
as a predator might have preyed on some
early genus of
horses due to a temporal overlap if this
is indeed the case the idea of a whale
which ate horses
is well quite jarring to say the least
speaking of early horses iraq ethereum
is an extinct genus of small
odd-towed ungulates basal to the ecwid
family a taxonomic classification which
eventually gave us the horse
as well as the donkey and the zebra
although not technically ecwid
themselves like they were once believed
hirak etherium still have quite the
evolutionary lineage which is impressive
considering just how tiny these species
were
these proto-horses maxed out at 9
kilograms or 20 pounds which is about
the weight of a miniature schnauzer
taking to the skies we have
oniconictriss a creature from the
earlier scene which looks
alarming from fossils alone but more
familiar in recreations
that's right it's the bat or a more
primitive taxonomic ancestor of the
modern bats we're familiar with
analysis of the bone structure suggests
on iconic tryst could already fly
and probably already echolocate indeed
compared to the other species
it seems early bats already had it all
figured out evolutionarily speaking
up next is a middle eocene animal i felt
i had to mention
that andrew sarkis is an extinct genus
which might have been the largest
predatory mammal
ever to walk the earth the three foot
long wolf-like skull alone we've
uncovered suggests an
animal even larger than a modern grizzly
bear
so what is this early mammal the
ancestor of well
not much actually most scientists think
that andrew sarkis has no direct
evolutionary lineage whatsoever
and was an offshoot which simply died
out proving in biology as well as life
you can never tell who will succeed long
term based on
early signs of promise ending our
adventure through first draft of mammals
we have
the omomaya day a group of early
primates with
massive eyes similar to the startling
peepers on a modern-day tassiere
so what are these perpetually shocked
looking animals the ancestors of
you and i well maybe it's difficult to
say for certain if omomaya day are
direct evolutionary ancestors of humans
and other apes but it's certainly
possible based on the fossil record
if so our ancestors weighed about 500
grams or
just over one pound pretty tiny
despite this they had some early
versions of features you might recognize
on yourself
like grasping hands with complex digits
it's difficult to know much else about
these organisms due to the scattered
nature of their remains but if they are
an early branch in our family tree you
might be looking at your
evolutionary baby photo to put it a
certain way
and with that our journey through the
early versions of mammals you might
recognize
comes to an end i hope you enjoyed this
video and learned a thing or two along
the way
if you did please consider subscribing
and leaving this video a like
it costs nothing and would help me out a
lot thank you so much for watching and
i'll see you in the next video